new haircut Otis hey everyone how's it
going I hope you are well and quick note
thank you to felix great for sponsoring
today's video we're gonna be talking
about their blue light walking glasses
later on so stay tuned so anyone who
works at a desk job in tech and
especially as software engineers we
spend a lot of time in front of screens
in general like your job is kind of
literally to look at screens but that
can cause a lot of issues it's
particularly for eye strain so today
we're going to talk about my experience
with it is it real you actually get ice
rain in a software engineering job and
then also talk about what are the actual
effects of working on a screen and what
are the problems and why should you care
and then we're going to talk about all
the solutions all of the solutions a lot
of which I've done myself to improve my
quality of life when looking at screens
all day also I should preface by saying
that I am NOT a medical professional I'm
not an optometrist anything like that at
all so this is just advice from one
person to another on how I think that
y'all can help your eyes basically but I
will leave links in the description that
box down below of research that has been
done in this area by people in this
space oh and also if you haven't click
subscribe yet please do I'm almost at a
quarter of a million subscribers and it
would be great to get up there soonish
so if you're not subscribed how I love
one of your subscriptions please thank
you okay so let's start with the big
question here which is have I
experienced eye strain after I started
as a software engineer and the answer is
heck to the yes I have so for me the way
that I experienced all of this and
realized something was going on was that
I started getting a lot of headaches my
eyes were also very dry and I noticed
that my context didn't really feel like
they were like fitting in my eye very
well and I noticed that I was getting
poor quality of sleep and having
really hard time shutting down my eyes
when going to bed and this whole thing
is a problem it sucks because it affects
your quality of life it affects your
quality of work what you can do during
your waking hours and it's something
that I think everybody who spends a lot
of time in front of screens should
figure out what that means to them and
find ways of mitigating these effects
because losing sleep getting headaches
not being able to fall asleep or wake up
well those are all things that are just
really hard to deal with and I don't
like them so a little bit of the science
behind I strain so I strain is like your
eyes are just working way too hard at
things but one of the big factors that
affect eye strain is blue light so blue
wavelengths in the color spectrum are
really beneficial during the daytime
because it increases response time and
increases alertness but we don't need it
all the time because we have a thing
called a circadian rhythm and a
circadian rhythm is basically an
internal clock that tells you when you
should wake up and when you should go to
bed and it's something that we have
evolved with our human bodies just know
how to do and our cycle is around 24
hours long so part of our bodies that is
making the circadian rhythm happen is
melatonin which is a hormone that
regulates the sleep/wake cycle and blue
light affects the secretion of melatonin
and therefore your circadian rhythm and
affects sleep your mood sometimes can
lead to really harmful diseases and
cancers and it really affects your sleep
and just your rhythm of life and lack of
sleep is not good it is linked to
depression it's linked to diabetes
cardiovascular problems it's a mental
illness that just really sucks to deal
with and blue light and light at night
in general affects these things there's
been a lot of research done around the
effects of blue light one firm Harvard
Health which I'll leave in the
description box down below but it really
is like a thing we use a lot of screens
all the time and our bodies are just not
evolved to be used
okay cool so blue light all the time is
not natural it's not good not getting
enough sleep is not good feeling
discomfort in the eyes is also not good
we just can't live our best life and do
our best work and write our best code if
we don't respect and give our bodies
what it needs so now let's talk some
solutions and I think the first thing is
kind of this foundational like almost
pre work part of it all which is just
around I health and that's around going
to the optometrist and getting your eyes
checked once a year to make sure that
you have the right prescription for your
eyes and then also getting your eyes
looked at to make sure that it's healthy
and I think within eye health is stuff
like eye dryness and eye drop so
noticing when your eyes are dry and
giving it the moisture that it means for
me I went to the optometrist it was like
yo my eyes are really dry and I wear
contacts all the time like what's up and
they gave me a different kind of contact
lens that is way more moisturize
moisturize moisturize up being these
daily contact because I was on bi-weekly
before that really really helped with
the dryness in my eye
number two is something called the
20-20-20 rule which is you're supposed
to look away from your screen every 20
minutes at something 20 feet away for 20
seconds I learned about this rule after
moving to Silicon Valley and it's
generally just look away from the screen
once in a while you can set a timer for
yourself for every 20 minutes there's
apps out there that help you do this so
that you're making sure that your eyes
are not literally glued to the screen
for super long a lot about time I should
recommend this trick and I recommend
this one as well so number three is
screen improvements and there's a lot of
things in this umbrella most notably are
things like night shift or flux or
anything to make your blue screen turn a
little bit redder especially as the Sun
Goes Down I've noticed that ever since
night shift came out on iOS and on Mac
OS that has really helped with just the
strain on my eyes it doesn't get rid of
all blue light though because there is
still blue light on the screen and I'll
talk about how to mitigate
that even better in the next step but it
does get you a long way oh these things
are super easy to use you can set a
timer and do custom things with it but I
found that that's really helpful as well
as dimming your screen and having larger
text I know we want to fit all of the
things in a monitor screen but if you
are literally squinting at the tiniest
little text that is going to cause I
shrink you are going to make your eyes
work harder and really bright screens is
also just like a freaking flood of blue
light you're letting into your eyes as
well
so only may be as bright as like your
surroundings I found really helps with
my headaches so the next tip is blue
light blocking glasses now blue light
blocking glasses literally block blue
light that's coming in from screens and
from elsewhere as well these ones are
from Felix gray and I love them a lot
these are called the Hamiltons and
they've been awesome especially as I get
to work I put these on and I wear them
the whole day and they've basically
eliminated all the headaches that I've
had from staring at a screen all day as
well as the really harsh bright white
lighting that is in my office
and they've made the world of a
difference business great is actually a
sponsor of this video which I'm super
excited about because I love their
glasses for a while now and they're
really good glasses compared to other
blue light blocking glasses out there
Felix gray filters out more blue light
than those other ones and also the blue
light blocking technology is embedded
within the lens itself instead of a
coating so you'll notice that on these
glasses the glare is not blue and it
also won't scratch off ever
these have been amazing at reducing eye
strain and I think a combination of this
as well as all the screen improvements
that I told you about have been probably
the biggest helps in terms of making
sure that I don't get ice rain and I
don't get headaches those are coming off
now because those are my prescription
ones and I also have contacts on and I
can't see anything but thank you huh
there used to be like computer glasses
that were more for gamers which we're a
little bit more sporty looking but
these basically do the same thing but
they're way more not sporty looking and
very trendy and they look good on me so
I'm very happy about that they've
actually got a promo going on right now
if you click the link below you'll see
it it's for a limited time but it's
great their glasses don't actually go on
sale that often so I hope you take
advantage of that link is in the
description box down below as well as
more details on how these glasses work
and thanks again to feel these great for
sponsoring these are so good and I'm
very happy about them and I'm happy to
be partnering with a company that is
making work just more comfortable really
so blue light blocking glasses you gotta
get them a lot of my friends who wear
glasses and our software engineers wear
blue light blocking glasses and they
found them to be really useful in
reducing eye strain and just like pain
in general and improving sleep and just
all of the health benefits that come
with that
so those are my tricks I think a
combination of these is really what you
have to do you can't just do one or two
I think doing all of them and practicing
them and working them into your
lifestyle will really help with the eye
strain and you can always try out
different things you can just not what
gonna screen for a little bit which is
always an option and hopefully that'll
make it a little bit easier to sleep and
also do work and just be your best self
and that's what I did I mean I I do all
of these in combination and I still do
and they've been really helping a lot I
mean really it just comes down to just
giving your body what it needs in this
case your eyes I think this in
conjunction with like sleeping well
eating well staying hydrated exercising
socializing like all of those things are
all really tied together and those are
all part of making you feel like you can
be your best self at work and otherwise
and it's important for you to do that
for yourself because you're the most
responsible person to take care of
yourself no one else is going to so
that's on you cool so that's it for
today I hope you enjoyed this video
thanks again Felix grey for sponsoring
all of the links that I talked about
will be in the
in box down below and I'll see you next
time bye
[Music]